édition spéciale de son économie
consacrée à l'impact économique de la
guerre en ukraine qui a été lancé par la
russie avec nous maintenant charles
aimons le pdg de la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec pour voir monsieur
monde et reçoit merci d'être avec nous
présentation des résultats financiers
aujourd'hui de la caisse de dépôt je
vous parle d'abord cela dit de cette
situation de l'ukraine
420 milliards de dollars d'actifs vous
êtes à la tête de l'une des plus grandes
caisses de retraite du monde quand on
voit ce qui se passe présentement qui
déstabilisent l'économie mondiale qui
déstabilise toute une région comment la
caisse de dépôt réagi baissé sur contre
avait déjà en amont depuis un bout de
temps parce qu'on voyait certaines
situations se développer on peut prévoir
exactement certaines choses mais ces
deux de se préparer pour certaines
situations qui ont nagé en conséquence
en ce sens là je te rassure l eau les
québécois là où il ya des impacts
évidemment dans l'économie d'une
situation comme ça mais le portefeuille
est en santé pour ne point de situation
l'ouest ont perdu des millions des
milliards de dollars aujourd'hui mais le
regard
stratégique économique que vous portez
c'est lequel aujourd'hui on fait face
quand même un signe tangible quand même
qui est là qui pourrait donner suite à
un nouvel ordre mondial il faut quand
même pas minimiser ce que ça en même
temps c'est un conflit qui pour
l'instant régional et on faisait face à
une situation parce qu'on avait poussée
de l'inflation vous inviter en ont parlé
puis des jeunes croissance le kit appelé
à assas et réduire un peu mais c'est
certain qu'avec une hausse du prix du
gaz naturel en europe une hausse du prix
du pétrole
on peut exacerber ces deux facteurs
l'eau dans la même direction l'inflation
continue la croissance se modère
davantage l'inflation c'est pas grave
tant que de la croissance est ce qu'on a
vécu en 2021 eu des bons résultats
messi est de l'inflation et plus de
croissance sauf qu'une combinaison peut
plus délicate est ce que la caisse de
dépôt 420 milliards d'actifs est exposé
à ce conflit là dont les textes pose
indirectement on peut pas en être
complètement isolé parce que le pétrole
monte le coût de l'énergie le gaz
naturel sain intrants pour les
compagnies c'est certain que l'europe va
être affecté mais regardez aujourd'hui
la réaction sur les marchés qui peut pas
toujours foi de tout il ya juste 24
heures les marchés européens la baisse
mais les marchés américains après une
forte baisse ont fini à la hausse oui il
vous invite en ont parlé un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui est derrière ça c'est
qu'on est passé d'une situation complexe
une situation
compliquée la hausse des taux des
banques centrales dans cet environnement
était déjà délicat que l'atterrissage
faire pour ne pas trop modéré la
croissance tout en contenant l'inflation
mais là qu'est ce qu'on fait et
peut-être que le marché anticipe que les
hausses de taux à certains endroits
seront différentes ses taux comme
pronostics mais ces genres de choses
auxquelles on réfléchisse parce que ça
se pourrait que les réactions soient
différentes d'un marché à l'autre une
façon locale l'amérique du nord les
états unis l'europe tout se sera pas
affectée parfaitement de la même façon
mais il ya des impacts quand même à
moyen terme d'une crise comme ça le
globule même reporté aujourd'hui que
vous avez vendu la caisse des centaines
de millions de dollars en valeur
d'actions récemment dans cette
entreprise russe la caisse investit dans
des entreprises russes au 31 décembre
2020 selon la recension du globalement
un total de 36 entreprises russes dans
le portefeuille de la caisse de dépôt
est ce que c'est toujours le cas non en
fait on avait commencé à vendre plus tôt
on n'était pas obligé parce qu'on
respecte toujours les sanctions
canadiennes je tiens à dire mais
néanmoins parce que les sanctions sont
toujours à partir de maintenant par un
avant on a décidé de les vendre on n'a
pas de stratégie d'investir en russie
c'est à dernier produit je dirais
indiciels parce que évidemment la russie
fait partie du monde alors évidemment
avec des produits jeu des gestionnaires
externes c'est un indice mondial la
russie fait partie mon s'activent déjà
depuis quelques semaines a répliqué les
indices chez nous à l interne sortir de
ces contrôles à extraire la russie il
repas d'exposition pour le québec mais
vous en avez encore des actifs loués et
séminaires mais il ya une couverture
également là dedans puisque de la cayrié
une majeure pour les épouses mais
gazprom par exemple qui perd 40%
aujourd'hui est ce que ça fait la caisse
de dépôt il y avait déjà eu des ventes
qui avaient été faites à forts profits
sur ces titres indiqué vous avez parlé
des sanctions juste préciser les
sanctions en 2015 le canada va imposer
des sanctions en 2015 lors de l'invasion
de l'écrit mais vous des thoniers déjà
des actifs russes à ce moment là vers
des produits indiciels oui donc on
n'était pas légalement obligés de s'en
défaire s'en départir mon le fait
néanmoins dans les dernières semaines
dans les dernières semaines seulement
pourquoi avoir attendu si longtemps
légalement on pouvait c'est un indice
quand on a un marché où est-ce qu'on a
un marché émergent par exemple les
indices comporte les russies alors c'est
du sélect des gestionnaires externes à
l'extérieur de résilier ses contrôles là
c'est un peu plus complexe mais on le
fait pour ne garder ça c'était des 18
qui ont été profitables mais dans le
contexte actuel la position de
l'institution ces deux rien à voir en
russie de toute façon il n'y a pas de
stratégie il ya pas de thèse
d'investissement n'y a pas de conviction
à vers ce marché résultat aujourd'hui
rendement on valoir à l'écran de 13,5
pour cent en 2021 actifs nets 420
milliards de dollars
par ailleurs les placements privés 39 2
% le rendement dans les placements
privés les marchés boursiers 16,2 pour
cent les immeubles les infrastructures
13,6 pour cent obligation revenu fixe
une baisse de 0,6 pour ça et une en fait
d'abord et avant tout vous avez
largement profité du rebond de l'année
2021 plus que vos pairs et plus que l'
indice de référence oui pour l'année
très fier en fait c'est des résultats
record au cours des dix dernières années
on a battu lundi ce de façon
significative ces 10 milliards de valeur
ajoutée et les stratégies qu'on a mis en
place dès le milieu de l'année 2020
après cogné un diagnostic après le choc
de la pandémie l'homme mars avril on est
mis en place des stratégies de reprise
seulement marchés boursiers en
immobilier et donc depuis 18 mois on a
beaucoup de valeur ajoutée qui a été
créée cette performance l'âme satisfait
beaucoup de ce point de vue là vous êtes
sûr su en grande partie des centres
commerciaux des tours à bureaux mais on
a changé en fait le portefeuille mobile
il c'est un 180° en 18 mois cent
soixante dix transactions sont en
portefeuille de 65 milliards puis je
vous donne une statistique les secteurs
porteurs la logistique résidentiel
l'industriel commerçants en ligne sont
est passé de 28 % du portefeuille
immobilier à 42% sont les bons secteurs
al'inverse les secteurs traditionnels en
déclin bureau traditionnel centres
commerciaux sont passés de 45 à 31 %
seulement 18 mois on a donc maintenant
plus de secteurs porteurs que l' inverse
ça c'était la situation à l'opposé à
seulement dessus mais quelle est la part
de risque quand on comparer ce que nous
étaient laquelle je sais pas quand tout
le monde se rappelle de l'écrasement de
2008 mais la part de risque aujourd'hui
de la caisse de dépôt on un portefeuille
pour moi aujourd'hui qui est encore plus
en santé mieux positionné nos
portefeuilles mieux diversion immobilier
on n'a plus d'actifs qui performent donc
d'être concentré à certains endroits
plus qu'une classe d'actifs deviennent
un peu dans un déclin structurel donc de
ce point de vue là je suis très fier du
pivot qui était fait mais c'est pas au
prix d'un risque additionnel mais on a
une construction de portefeuille sont
des assises plus solides et on verra
donc comment ça va se passer en 2022
ça va vite souvent à chaque fois qu'on
se rend compte il ya un événement puis
quelques mots plus tard il s'est pas
assez complètement autre chose alors on
verra merci beaucoup monsieur merci à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]